yeah so i'm just gonna share a little
debugging story with you and um
i just it's it's not really um
maybe in the end the bug is is not
terribly complex but i still feel it
uh contains all of the essence of what i
find exciting about
programming you know and that is the
unexpected uh
so one day a bunch of my co-workers came
back from lunch
and they discovered that everyone's copy
of chrome had crashed
and it would just keep crashing it was
like no you could not open crash
so obviously productivity plummeted to
zero uh
and and i thought this was wonderful
already but uh
um but you know um first principle of
debugging you isolate what
changed and you know so the question was
um well was there just like a chrome
update and that killed everything but
there was nothing online
um no evidence this was anywhere else
but here so you're like well what else
um you know what else happened uh you
know in our environment and
the only other thing is we had bought
this printer
and then we got suspicious because we
had named the printer
uh an emoji we had named it printer
emoji
so we unplugged the printer right and
chrome stopped crashing
and then uh we plugged it in again and
boom
all everybody's copy of chrome on the
entire network
crashed and so okay
you know obviously we start debugging
this but i have to say i said this is
this is the greatest day of my life
that's how excited that's how excited i
got i get about
issues like this um so what was the
first thing
first approach for this uh so the first
thing that i did is i dove
into gdb on um on the system
now this is actually only mac os chromes
this was a
company with a lot of almost everyone
was running macs so
pretty pretty dominant um on mac os
you'd usually use lldb but uh
old dogs new tricks i'm sort of more
comfortable with gdb
so anyway we see here that like um
chrome is crashing in
strln which is the c standard library
function get the length of a string
um and uh so that initially is really
exciting because
uh something terrible is probably
happening right
and uh um but we we go into
of course chrome is an open source
although we'll get to
more of that later um but um
at the very least we can always we can
always disassemble uh
we can always look at the registers
that's one of my favorite things to do
the
the registers after a program has
crashed often tells such a fascinating
story
they tell us all sorts of places it's
been but in this case uh
i actually it's a pretty boring
registered dunk we can see that
in particular like the stack is is fine
all these things are fine
and rdi which is the first argument to
strlen
is zero so we just have a null pointer
dereference
it's still exciting because we can
reduce productivity in the office to
zero anytime we want but
you know we can't we can't necessarily
make chrome dance for us
so the next step is well what's
happening what is the printer
doing uh and so we turned to
an excellent tool um called tcp dump and
there actually is a
an amazing zine that just came out uh
that's that should be available here i
think maybe uh that will talk that will
tell you all about tcp dump and how
wonderful it is and
and and how to use it so i won't say too
much about that
but i do want to mention um paired with
that is another tool that
uh i really love which is called tcp
replay
which allows you to replay packet dumps
so you
tcp dump spies on your network shows you
what packets are going by your network
interface
a tcp replay lets you replay those
packets right
so this was a way for us to figure out
um
what what traffic is actually causing
this problem and so we apply an idea
from
property testing and if you don't
already know what property testing is
and you don't already do it you should
come up to me afterwards and talk to me
about it because
i think it's a really important idea and
actually we have the author of
an excellent c property testing library
called theft here with us it's wonderful
library you should check it out
but a really interesting idea from quick
check and all these things
is the shrinking of inputs so uh
you have some we captured a bunch of
traffic where the printer was spewing
out its weaponized emoji
and you know and then we we bisect it
and we
we chop it down until tcp replay is just
playing back
um you know just the packets that are
causing this problem
it turns out it's these two packets and
then nicely we can package into a script
you know
starbucks.sh that
that triggers the problem wherever we
like um
you know it's very very convenient
uh but so uh what are these packets
um so these are these are mdns packets
uh which is the
multicast dns uh and of course it's like
notable
or i immediately looked at the rfc um
oh actually i'll get back to that i
looked at the rfc and there's this sort
of quote
that i enjoyed uh that you know the the
obvious elegant solution is that
everything should be encoded as utfh um
and of course so we look at these
packets this is what the the packs look
so
mdns is um the
you know basically so dns is this glue
that that uh
sort of essentially keeps the internet
together mdns is this
is this is a very similar protocol but
just for local service discovery
but something that's interesting about
it is it sort of changes the
um kind of the inverts the relationship
uh between servers and clients because
basically unlike dns where you're asking
a server for something
in mdns you're just constantly being
bombarded by packets from
every device on your network like this
printer right
but anyways this printer is advertising
itself we can see that the service name
is a8 downstairs printer downstairs
that actually worked right but this uh
txt ty register so this is some kind of
google google clown print thing that i
don't understand
uh that's some new feature but the the
type
um record here is obviously not uh
encoded correctly and um so we look at
this
so something that i mean i noticed
emojis have been a part of every
successful talk here
right so we can't deny their vast
importance
um but you know so one of the ways that
emojis are represented is
unicode which has this large space and
then you have um
different ways of how do you actually
represent unicode on the wire
so the most common way and what mdns is
supposed to use is utf-8 which is
actually this really elegant encoding
except for the fact that
there's lots of um there's lots of
sequences of bytes you can generate that
aren't valid utf-8
right and in this case the printers is
spewing out um
like f08da0bd f08d
b6 a8 so this sequence that's twice as
long as what we would expect
and it turns out that this is like a
utf-8 encoding of
a utf-16 encoding of the printer emoji
right so some classic uh classic kind of
problem but
um wasn't wasn't caught in time anyway
why does this cause chrome to crash
so luckily of course there's a sort of
an open source version of chrome called
chromium
and we're able to reproduce the problem
there uh you know and it turns out that
it's like
it's very simple problem um so we can
see here that
we're uh creating this this uh string
and initializing it with
these bytes that we received off the
wire which is always
always a tenuous thing i think you
always want to be very careful when
doing that
although in this case it's not nearly as
much fun as we had hoped
the key thing here is we're asking for
this nsutf8 string encoding
and if we actually look at the core
foundation documentation
this says well this returns nil if uh
record bytes isn't uh valid utf-8 and so
it isn't so that's where our null
pointer dereference comes from so it
turns out the the fix
that um you know restores productivity
in the office is just this
like almost a one-liner uh kind of thing
and so
um yeah i said you know submitted that
and unfortunately
the the because it was technically a
security issue
uh the the bug was sealed for a long
time and it took some poking in patches
before
it finally got uh fixed but um
you know and so all's well it ends well
except that
actually you know this printer is still
lurking right it's still sending out its
weaponized packets and uh
i tried to contact hp um to
report this there was just no way to get
in contact with anyone responsible
and probably it's hard to fix anyway
it's probably you know
that upgrading that firmware is
difficult but consider this their their
public shaming
um in any case you know it was uh
a really simple uh thing in the end but
it just was lovely going through all
these systems and having this such an
unexpected
huge uh result from such a tiny thing
uh i think is is really the the essence
of
uh you know of the the unexpected which
is is what's so exciting about uh
programming
um so anyway i think if there's a moral
to that story uh
it's uh that everyone should go out and
stuff every input field with emoji uh
thank you
[Applause]